listen clay has been my and i told him
this off here
you've been my quarantine mvp i listen
to you when i ride my bike i listen to
the podcast
when i'm i'm out there for about two
hours so i listen the whole show
and uh yeah it's just like you're my
go-to then i use
i regurgitate your facts i'm not as
smart as you but i'll regurgitate the
facts
so you're basically i'm just cheating
off you and then i regurgitate on this
show and to the rest of my friends
and like damn he really knows his stuff
but i'm just using your stuff
i i appreciate that look i i i said this
before you if you listen to the show you
know what i'm talking about like
i tend to whenever there's a danger or
fear
i want to know everything about it
almost like if i'm in a fight with
uh with the media because i feel like
there's so much what i've been calling
fear porn out there
convincing everybody hey you're all
gonna die never leave your homes doesn't
matter what it is
and so from the get-go here uh since
this thing started back in february
i've been tracking it and uh and i just
think the media as a group
has done an awful job of actually
explaining
the real danger for your average person
out there and as a result
i think we've made a lot of really bad
decisions that aren't justified by the
data
well that's what surprised me is why in
the world
wouldn't somebody who's reasonable look
at the actual data
i understand that in the beginning
nobody knew what this was and they were
terrified that the hospitals would be
overrun
and there were projections that said
that this thing could be very deadly for
everybody
so you have to give some compassion to
everybody who shut us down
even though it's never happened in our
history but but you know i can
understand
i i always called for a targeted
quarantine as soon as we learned that
the most vulnerable with people who are
older
you were saying that for a while though
weren't you you're saying they they
should be a target of quarantine i mean
i think you look at the data
for from the very beginning and your
guys are raising the right questions i
think
we should have had a target in
quarantine right because around half of
all the deaths in this country have come
out of nursing homes
and nursing home residents represent i
think it's 0.6
of the entire american population uh if
you look at the data in pennsylvania
more people over a hundred have died
than people
under the age of 45 in the state of
florida big state
not one person under the age of 18 has
died
for people who are 24 and younger you
are more likely to be struck by
lightning than you are to die of the
coronavirus and yet my kids may not be
able to go to school get out there
yeah and yet my 12 year old and my
eight-year-old may not be able to go to
school
because of this and i don't know how to
fight back i i
what drives me nuts is i don't feel like
i live in a representative democracy
and for whatever reason i feel like
there are there are
powerful elements in the in the media
that seem to
enjoy this shutdown they they they have
a job every day
and and the rest of people and i'm
really worried but that the fact that
most of the businesses that will fail
are small
businesses which is the backbone of this
country which is the middle class
and what's left then you know surprise
survives this large corporations so now
we have
a surf serfdom we've got a surf class
all who have to get a job
at either walmart amazon apple whatever
who've all done very well with this
clay did did you move to florida during
all this is that right
yeah it's a florida for the month of may
so i've got
a 12 a nine and a five year old three
boys myself and
so i obviously they matter more to me
than anything in the world but the fact
that they were out of school
makes no sense from a data perspective
right and
so i got so fed up with it you know we
were staying in our house we were trying
to follow the rules
but i said as soon as the states start
opening up and i'm
unfortunate i live in tennessee which is
a state that started to open up pretty
early in the nashville area
but then we went down to florida where
the beaches as soon as the beaches
started to open up i was like screw this
i'm going to spend may down at our i'm
fortunate to have a florida place down
there but i think you you hit on a
really
important detail here we have in this
society in our
america today if someone's feelings are
hurt by your facts then you aren't
allowed to share them
and you hit on a point i think
everybody's afraid to be fired
because of social media if you go on and
say which i've been saying hey look
7 500 people die every day in the united
states it sucks i wish we were immortal
i wish no one died but even if the
coronavirus
is actually taking the lives that it is
it's still a small proportion of the
number of people
that are going to die every year in this
country 2.8 million
people die every year in this country
it's unlikely i think we look at the
2020 data
that we're going to be able to see much
of a difference in overall death rate in
this country
than in 2019 or 2018 or 2017.
hey you think do you think do you think
that this reaction would have been
different
if donald trump wasn't president and do
you think you do
so do i i do i think look i think for
better or worse trump is so polarizing
that whatever he says people tend to
reject it because they don't trust him
or they don't like it
do you think i think people are yeah i
think we're polarized like i think
hillary would have had the same reaction
to a certain extent the fact that they
ran against each other
but i think if we had a middle of the
road president if we had had a george w
bush or if we'd had a bill clinton
somebody that
or maybe even a barack obama first term
i don't think people would have reacted
the same way with such intense
polarization
as they have
and he makes them respond emotionally
and when you respond emotionally you
don't make logical decisions
and i think our country has just been
responding emotionally
instead of using the facts yeah and
what's surprising to me too
is and you touch a lot on this like with
the nba coming back and they're doing
this weird
circumstance where you know they're in
florida although i can ride splash
mountain the players have to stay inside
so it's like this weird contradiction
but
adam silver has the same stats that you
have access to or have access to
yet they're flying all these guys down
and this is what made me laugh he goes
so the the teams are quarantined right
and
he's like well what are they gonna do
with all like you know everyone has side
pieces or they
they have you know their side pieces
like what they can do with the
quarantine side pieces then
it's a it's something funny we we laugh
at but it's a legit concern for these
players
like they're like what locked down for
18 weeks
i think adam silver is implementing a
plan that might have made sense
in the worst days of april by august and
the analogy i'm using first of all it is
funny to think if i were an nba player a
single nba player
and i was trying to get my girls in i
would be i would be like shawshank
redemption i'd be trying to probe all
the different you know like
bubble aspects of security guards who
can i bribe off
what can i do to get some girls into the
bubble you're not already
for 18 weeks but stay with me uh for
just a day or two right so
i would start there but when you can
ride every when you can go to harry
potter world
and when you can go to lego lane the nba
players are not going to be allowed to
leave a bubble inside of disney world
i think they are going to look
ridiculous because we're going to have
30 000 people at nascar
on july 15th yeah is that right
30 000 people yes 30 000.
where what state is that that's 20
of the population that ordinarily could
get in because it seats 150
000. but still on july 15th in tennessee
30 000 and you're telling me in october
the nba still going to be playing
without fans present it's crazy
it's crazy but plus i think that they
would wrap the nba finals in october
so that's right i mean but by august
september you're going to leave these
guys in there
when most societies can be back to
normal i'd assume by august and
september
so it's it's mind-blowing maybe you know
this the people that are driving this
narrative politicians listen very
closely to health
professionals and to other other people
it's these decisions aren't made by
gavin newsom alone for example he's got
a group of people around him that are
telling 15 different things
is is this it was this a situation and
is it still a situation i don't know if
you know this
where health bureaucrats uh and i don't
mean that in a disparaging way but they
are
health they're they're health officials
and we know that people who are doctors
are good people but they're very
cautious they're typically very very
cautious
are they the ones who are calling all
the shots here
what's going on like how did this how
did this shutdown last
this long so first of all
i haven't gotten everything right so let
me say this because you'll probably hear
oh claytrap like when i initially we had
bad data initially
all right so when china came out with
lies
and you looked at the chinese data and
you tried to combine that with what we
were seeing
elsewhere back in february and then you
started to see the outbreak in italy
the data didn't line up yeah and so i
think the big flaw here
from the get-go was we had
epidemiologists who were
well-intentioned
attempting to build models based on
flawed data and i'm not a great
mathematician
but if you don't know what the death
rate is and you don't know what the
infection rate is
and you don't know what the uh what what
any of those numbers are
then when you put those into your
epidemiological models
they spew out all sorts of crazy results
so
you had this model out of england the
imperial
uh college model which forecasts that
2.2 million people
would potentially die in the united
states and so i think you saw that get
put
on the desk of all the governors and all
the
and all the presidents and everybody
else in the white house before we even
knew my god if this happens this is
unlike anything we've ever seen before
but it was a flawed model
and we followed flawed models which were
way in excess of what the reality we
also we also
i've heard that it's not a respiratory
disease i've heard it's actually a blood
disease
so they so we didn't know yeah there are
so many
different things we still don't know
well about this virus
that for instance we heard all the time
about how much we needed ventilators
and then later we found out actually
treating people with ventilators might
be a negative in terms of being able to
save them so
we have been trying to learn on the fly
and i think
the original sin here was we bought into
what china told us and what the world
health organization told us
which allowed us to rely on data that
wasn't real myself included as somebody
who was paying attention to all of this
and we've had to try to catch up to the
perceptions which have not been
necessarily reflected
in real data and we haven't done a good
job i think initially i've said this
look
if we wanted to shut down for a couple
of weeks back in march because we really
didn't know what we were doing
you could justify that as a safer than
sorry measure
but the idea that anybody's still locked
down right now
anywhere in this country is insanity
i'll tell you this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected